how's it going bros today we're doing i
laugh side my editor gets a race
hell yeah you ready for this am i gonna
lie yes yes
well we'll see about that all right i
gotta make sure i actually don't laugh
all right miley cyrus what you got like
all of a sudden i'd be trying to prove
that i'm not crazy when i knew i wasn't
crazy
that counts as a half point half point
as long as i get you laughing that's all
that counts for me
god
up shut the [ __ ] up i hate this it's so
annoying
why is it spanish too i love that
i don't know i think it's italian
actually oh
oh yeah you're right
i might say it's going to banish me
i just love the smile at the end
i find you get one tiny race okay here
we go one pound oh my god one batteries
oh you're welcome right uh welcome to
hell's kitchen first things first party
rockers in the house tonight okay well
actually gordon it's party rock is yeah
right
sure it is big boy
[Music]
why did you do this
why did you do this i should remove race
for you for this
that's awful it's just the random aspect
i guess isn't it yeah i did not i got to
be honest i did not expect that i'm well
played
this one is one of my favorite memes man
this one
okay we're we're wrapping this up i like
it all right chinese restaurants in the
hood be like how am i happy
i think i'm gonna do your general
chicken with rice
okay okay
and i'm going to egg roll with it
it come with that well
it come with edward
and what
it smells like when i'm in italy and i
don't underst like i see everyone
laughing i don't understand the joke but
i started to kind of like start laughing
a little bit because i kind of get it
and i think i get it and it's like funny
in my head and then they explain that
i'm like oh no i was laughing at
something else what the [ __ ] is this
side
this is
zoomer comedy 2021 it's like my brain
automatically laughs at any fine
sound effects is this saying chicken and
egg white
chicken egg roll
[Music]
with it
that was good though i like that
and then i hated it
you're trying to get me done here this
is it
what do you mean asian baby just died
what the hell
how do you like watching kids [ __ ]
crying
you know what you said you do you know
[Music]
you know what you know what some [ __ ]
dad saw recorded this and saw it i was
like that's [ __ ] funny i'm uploading
this
yeah yeah that means we're good we're
good
[Music]
what do you
what do you want to say about this one
what do you do comment
i actually i don't have any comment
either interesting
oh my god stop with it
i swear though like doesn't that just
make you laugh like anything with a vine
boom now unironically it's funnier isn't
it how does that work yeah you're you're
100 right
like what did i just watch usually they
get a brain freeze and it's funny and
they go ah
yeah this is kind got good there got me
oh i seeing that oh okay
the whole joke didn't read this i was so
focused on the vine oh wow what a dirty
girl oh man
what a [ __ ] jesus christ
i got no comment
shout out charlie it's so funny
that's the only reason i laugh
starting to slowly regret this but let's
keep going
there's a certain theme going on here
it's funny okay
it's literally what i see on twitter and
instagram
i remember in school we we we could pick
to study chinese and i regret so much
not doing that just for the me at this
point can you imagine the meme economy
what's this guy's name i forgot
he's like
i think he did a pewdiepie one is this
the pewdiepie one because i haven't seen
the video then
i just ate some of your
mr beast burger and let me tell you your
burger makes for a better fleshlight
than food i spent the last 20 minutes
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of this burger
you held that one well thank you thank
you
[Music]
damn
hey
what
what why
we're just getting started you cannot
just do the setup of a joke and no
punchline side you understand this
[Laughter]
that's the best one i've seen
let's go
well now when i see a black and white
video i i can only explain
expect one thing
all right almost done scanning my mom
still
oh yeah oh that's such a good move
devlin i love it
what is wrong with moms doing this to
every child every child can relate to
this horrible experience right why did
they all do it it just slays you when
you're younger yeah the drama we were
all inflicted but the thing is the
cashier the [ __ ] cashier always like
looks at you like
super mad like it's your fault mom
hasn't come back yet right like dude i'm
just a child be nice and be like that's
fine we can win
no one ever did that
influence gamer gives wholesome
motivational speech your life is
everything you serve all purpose you
should kill yourself now
and give somebody else a piece of that
oxygen
ozone layer
cover it up so that we can breathe
inside this blue trap
man makes a fair point damn let's go
there you're [ __ ] up man
no i'm joking bro come on no not this
again
whoa you should kill yourself
now
you should treat yourself now and give
yourself a piece of that oxygen in the
ozone
oh man that's good that's actually good
i knew what the punchline was but then i
forgot that it happens twice for
poor guy poor guy yeah
let me give you some context to this
number one who the watches dubs by the
way okay
[Applause]
this is the english dub this is the
english dead all right
are you mr cho wu's mother uh yeah
yes this is not real that's not right
100 this is a fan this is a fandom oh no
no no no needs to be now on business in
the united states uh
why do you ask sir well we're the police
i'm afraid that mr chosung-wu has a
warrant out for his arrest he's charged
with forgery embezzlement crimes that
are all
some form of financial fraud
huh
[ __ ] italian germans all this you
they think this is normal they're like
yeah it sounds really good i mean to be
fair like every other country has decent
dubs apart from [ __ ] english oh
that's a good point actually i guess
that industry is not as developed so
when they do it yeah that makes sense
that's why
don't be surprised if one day i just
there you go
hey
ah that's nice
i clearly i i forgot i they're supposed
to not laugh god damn it okay yeah i
forgot all right now we're back
one two ed sheeran also makes me laugh i
don't know why then we can sit right
here
one two three
[Music]
oh hell yeah
hell yeah i love that you were laughing
you were like yeah definitely 100 love
that that was amazing
did he ask people to do it
yeah
that's what makes it funny i mean i'm
not hating on the guy but like gas
station in france they were selling and
sharing books and i'm like really
phys might be down to do a meme review
with you right we don't hate you oh [ __ ]
all right that that would actually you
know
that would help you actually
people would think you like cringe if
you did anything come on
[Music]
oh there's a club banging come on man
is it just an owl sound
[Music]
oh that's good i did not expect that
when that owl went who bro i got him bro
i got him bro we need the remix
we need the nightcore remix on that [ __ ]
you laughed at that that was the one of
the worst ones by the way
i don't know at least
i didn't spoil the
punish line how to make madame cinnamon
all right
[Music]
the music is doing a lot here i feel
like
i just died because you just legit like
other quickly just said how to pick
methamphetamine you just read the time
oh i'm losing it i don't think it means
i like that we're censoring this [ __ ]
this is really good
it's literally real i've laughed like
twice right
yes
yeah all right
when you're on the phone with your girl
but you're popping off on the game
and you know basically you know
and you know
it's funny because it's relatable we've
all been there
come on
you're on the phone you're just going
yeah
people still playing cod come on get out
here all right we got joe biden means
night coming up you are the pope and
having a meeting with joe biden alright
what do you think about california
you like it yes do you like it
you taking a [ __ ]
[Music]
what you doing
you can't just have that caption through
that video you can do that's illegal i
think you can relate to this one
significantly oh
god damn it no
when someone asked how much you've
invested in diarrhea coins estimation of
somewhere between
700 billion and a trillion 300 million
billion dollars
somewhere in between million billions
gazillions
all right well if joe biden that's going
to go to the moon man yep honestly why
has no one done that like everyone tried
to copy dodge coin with all these other
like meme coins right but no one took it
to that level of just like complete coin
yeah like actually like that's what he
needed
it's not gonna work now idiots
goddamn wait what is this oh no
i need better this is not that funny i
just included for the sake of you this
is me on the left then who's on the
right i can't see i i don't know look
like some unboxing channels
dude
[Music]
i know right beauty bye mr bestie
mr bestie
i thought we should change it pewdiepie
no i mean when he's in pewdiepie i agree
this is an actual ad by [ __ ] amazon
no by the way
holy yeah you're right likes it's 100
real no
you failed to educate me
excuse me excuse you
[Music]
my grandma died oh no
sorry no
and i have a grandma
you're going to h3o see your g up there
she's not even dead not yet
at least i have good grades at least i
have a grandma
dale
[Laughter]
there's one too many chinese in here man
we can move on bro no no i love it
let's go
[Music]
now it's the walk it's the walk i got it
i got it
[Music]
12th birthday happy birthday billy wow
internet on the go 13th birthday
[Music]
not that i have any problem with tommy
in it and george like you guys are cool
i i have a problem i hate them all i'm
just kidding uh but
their friends are [ __ ] scary dude
they're insane and i don't want to hear
it listen you're well i shouldn't listen
to your opinion god damn yeah that was a
mistake bro no kids were missing
on the internet god damn
oh
oh yeah
let's go
[Music]
hey
okay i remember seeing a picture of a
sheep ass and i'm like damn i'm thinking
of myself i kind of get it
[Music]
suddenly welsh people you know they
don't seem so pathetic anymore okay
like bro
i get it it's okay dolandar what do we
got little changes of the poster
mr duckworth
class is not for sleeping
so the poets in this
post-industrialistic time frame how if i
can't move this whole [ __ ] out of
nowhere
it's the dark world
hey
damn i need a full version
[Music]
not that one all right this is the okay
if you could choose whatever we're doing
lucky dip from now i like that all right
we got ninja send me
your dick pics
okay
next thing that that's great oh no since
chinese parents say where are you going
go do homework
why door always closed go to sleep
sure they did say that
all the chinese kids in this video can
relate
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is happening
you roasted me for laughing remember
last week yeah
what is it i don't get it
there's no context needed bro just
add me a tears bruh you can't just show
two random clips and say that's funny
right in 2021 all comedy is like auto
generated right
i thought it was real for a minute and
that's why it's funny and i went into
some mickey mouse [ __ ]
all right so that's enough that's all i
can afford all right you're done you're
done son
all right that's a good i appreciate
that i appreciate that too man no that's
fun all right you know another one well
what was the rule you said uh you know
we set a goal last time if they wanted
another they got it he hit 500k last
time that's crazy 500.
no yeah yeah i was like that's not gonna
happen don't forget about that
600k all right well then
all right
[Applause]
i i subscribe 750k 750. see you next
time
bye bye